der Bundespräsident verleiht Großkreuze
ich verleihe jetzt mal den
wendehals-wort also grüne SPD auch die
Linkspartei fallen weg die machen ihren
Blödsinn konsequent seit 10 20 Jahren
aber nehmen wir mal die CDU eine
Hitliste des Grauens und die CSU Markus
Söder will nichts mehr davon wissen dass
er sich angegliedert hat an die
klimakaoten und für die Abschaltung der
Kernkraftwerke vehement war und der
Bruder ihn wird das nicht unbekannt sein
die Achse des Guten hat gerade vor
wenigen Stunden auf ihre Seite gestellt
ein Selbstgespräch mit Markus Söder 2001
und jetzt der Wendehals pur ein Schutz
und Schild für
Handwerker für Familienbetriebe und für
freie Berufe heute machen sie das exakte
Gegenteil was sie ihren Wählern
versprochen